[Music]
Thanks time we have a little
conversation about how to do libraries
and C++ now it's the thing about
libraries C++ and just about any other
language eventually someone comes along
and makes a package manager for them but
there is no standard and that's where
the problem comes in there are so many
different ways to do C++ libraries and
it's you know like furred for JavaScript
there's node for whatever there's
whatever like every language there's
something Python has pip I'm trying to
think of other one who camel has some
something to every language of ever
checked out and they got into a little
bit always has something
you
sleep plus plus libraries I searched for
this I just get a bunch of C++ libraries
are used commonly like boost poco which
is a soft word network stop yes io again
some of these I'm going to use some of
these I have but how do you include them
that that's where sometimes people will
get stuck and there's a couple different
ways you can do a statically you can do
it dynamically or you can do some header
only build where it builds in with the
objects of your project that's the basic
ways and to briefly explain the
difference between static and dynamic
libraries I spelled that wrong but
whatever it'll correct there we go so
static libraries are copied per project
basically when you include a static
library you get a copy of the library
with whatever you're building when you
do a dynamic library the libraries
already built and you just use whatever
the functions out of it and it's not
built with your project so if you have
multiple projects and you don't want to
copy the library monster times use
dynamic if you want it to be fully
included on its own with your project to
use static both have their advantages
and disadvantages but that's the gist of
it dynamic will make you end up with
smaller object files typically but then
you have to include the dll or whoever
tries to run your project it's also run
time the dynamic is a runtime check so
when someone goes to run your program
they'll throw that dll error who doesn't
find it you've probably seen that before
pop-up but a static library will never
do that it's already built in but the
object file is larger so I guess the
header only is sort of like static okay
it's not actually but it basically is
built-in with your objects just the same
so it's not being reused from a single
dynamic library
there's Conan Conan IO which is a
open-source package manager that you can
generally use for everything I tried to
get started with this I spent about an
hour with Conan and I kind of got it
going it actually has you do everything
through Python which is a kind of cool I
guess but it was a little more named for
how when you read the answer an
introduction it makes it sound like it's
super simple and I can see that it kind
of is but you've got to understand a lot
of things before it gets simple and I
was starting to kind of get to the point
where it was starting to get simplified
for me but overall I'm not the biggest
fan in the world yeah I'm still gonna
play around with Conan may be able to do
a video later about Conan I oh let me
know if you'd like to see that but the
other one is VC package manager and as
you could see someone had as I was
typing it in VC package manager verse
Conan is a pretty popular thing so maybe
we could talk a little bit about that
but if you're using Microsoft stuff VC
package manager can do the same thing
you can go grab libraries that you need
so this is really you know it's
something you need to know as a
developer no matter what you're making
because you're gonna need Network
libraries you're gonna need windowing
libraries you're gonna need graphics
libraries and things like that so
anything you might need you can get
through these or you can not use these
at all and do it your own way
so that way you don't need to include a
package manager and worry about it you
can just do it your own way and actually
that's that's what I've come to have
used VC package manager a little bit
it's actually pretty nice but I just
don't like having additional
dependencies basically because now if
you want to work on the project you've
also gotta mess with the package manager
and that can be avoided and you can just
use git now how you want to include your
static and dynamic libraries is
ultimately up to you and there is no
proper standard you go to 20 different
places you're not gonna get 20 different
answers you'll probably get like five
different answers of people doing it
different ways and I want to talk a
little bit about kind of my favorite
kind of my sound like the sure no keep
saying kind of I want to talk about the
way I've recently been doing library
and this is a windows thing of ever all
I guess if I were on Linux I would
probably do it about the same it would
work about it could work about the same
except you just have to make a C make
file or a make file for it let me launch
Visual Studio here and I want to talk a
little bit about how I like to do
libraries I'm just gonna do a brand new
project that is empty well empty yeah do
an empty project just an empty project
here so it's just a new project and I'll
just call it including libraries I don't
deal so you can see there we go okay the
new version I think I'm actually ignore
that for now since I'm doing a video I'm
just gonna set this up a little bit okay
I'm gonna click on the project I'm gonna
click this show all files so it shows me
an actual structure of what's going on
and of course there's nothing because I
chose empty projects so what I'm gonna
do isn't right-click on this project and
go to add new item we're gonna do a CPP
file so it's gonna be an object file
something to build and we're gonna make
our main so we're gonna call it main dot
CPP and we'll just say and main and
return 0 of course or it'll be improper
we'll say exit success which is just 0
and to include that I've got to include
the C standard why there is that's a
that's some terrible formatting right
there alright so there we go we'll just
make it a little more proper real quick
okay so there's our main so if we build
this we build an any configuration it'll
run fine it's not gonna do anything
except return a 0 and yeah there goes
unable to start operator 2 not completes
successfully because the file contains a
virus or potentially unwanted software
this is a really weird error to get I
have never seen this error actually
operation did not complete successfully
because the file contains a virus or
potentially unwanted software WTF
there are so-called false positives that
occur to false injuries in the malware
database this is often a false positive
wait what thing is this and I'm so
confused 86'd bug yeah it's x86 debug
that doesn't that throws the error
that's really strange we're gonna ignore
that okay so now let's talk about
including libraries let's say let's pick
a common library and just use it as a
sample and now I'm talking about open
source libraries here there's a lot of
open source libraries that you can use
and if you want to only use open source
you don't need a package manager you can
just independently build them on your
own so let's say I want to and say I
want to use GL fw3
which is a win OpenGL windowing system
OpenGL Vulcan context windowing system
which is pretty commonly used with C++
if you're doing graphics because it
works on both Windows Linux and Mac all
three boast I said both cuz I was going
to say Windows and Linux but it will
throw a Mac in there too it's it's a
survivor so GL FW how do you include it
you could do it through Conan you can do
it through VC package manager
you see package manager might actually
be the easiest just because we're ever
using Visual Studio but what if you
don't even wanna mess with that you just
want to build the latest version of GL
left over yourself and then and use that
library because it's open source you
should be able to do that right well you
can let's go ahead and go to jail off W
you can see it down or download the
latest version that they released or you
can see a cloned so we're gonna actually
click well let's go we're for example
let's click on the download first and
see what does it actually download the
zip of it okay
whatever that's fine so you can use this
file to do it I'm not gonna do that
right now though I'm gonna use do a
clone that way I get the latest version
with my project all the time so we're
gonna hit this clone button and copy the
link now you can clone with visual
studios get
I'll have that set up right now so I'm
gonna launch program called fork
actually forget fork let's use git bash
keep bashes even cooler okay I think my
repos are actually on a different Drive
so I'm Scott I'm gonna go to my key
Drive I'm gonna go to well let me see
what I got here I think I have in
storage
yeah CD storage is where I keep my
projects so you basically I'm just
basically going to where I keep my
projects there's a bunch of stuff in
storage oh wow
okay well I'm gonna go to run burritos
I'm pretty sure that's in here now it's
under source Jesus I've got a lot of
files on this on this hard drive source
repos there we go and then there we go
so I've got a bunch of other projects in
here already I have glue but I don't
have GL @ w3 so let's go ahead and clone
glf w3 we'll just do a git clone and I
should have that link still copied so
I'm going all right click and do a paste
oh it's glue my blue copy no copy so you
basically just want this link of course
you're off to set up a kit I assume you
already did that and we're just gonna
clone it and we're gonna clone it into
the folder we're in right now and let it
do its thing so now we can change
directory into that folder and - jail -
well let's just look at it yeah there it
is GLW and of course if you go into gfw
you will see that it has all its files
and a/c make build stuff so what we want
to actually do next is just launch C
make C make GUI is what I'm using here
on Windows and we're just gonna go ahead
and build it so we're gonna go same
folder except this time we're gonna go
to GL w and then that's fine that's
where the source code is basically the
routes he make file then we want to
decide where to build the
binary's there's already kind of got to
make some choices about where you want
to be doing your includes and stuff so
I'm just actually gonna do it on the
root of this repo which usually people
make a build folder but I have my
reasons for doing it on the root on this
particular project so we're gonna source
code and build in the same spot in this
case like I said usually people do a
build folder here but I'm just not doing
that purposely because really it's
because of the way gfw has to see make
files and makes they include a little
weird if you have the build folder to me
anyway but it you could do it that way
it's fine you'll just have to make some
adjustments later so there it goes it's
doing its thing didn't find oxygen
didn't find some stuff but it all
configured and didn't have any errors so
we're gonna open the project with Visual
Studio because that's what we generated
for and now we want to build for the
version of our other project so we see
here we've got debug 64 if we want to
build that one we'll just go to build
build solution and it's gonna build
whenever the project it's on which is an
all build currently so that's probably
gonna generate all the libraries
actually look at this output yeah it's
still going
32 succeeded so bill no just bill all
the debug 64 stuff so if we also maybe
we want release 64 as well so we'll go
ahead and build that one we're only
gonna build the 64 bit ones but as you
can see here you can also build the 32
bit ones if you want to build your other
project 32 there's libraries do have to
match debug release 32 64 so I built the
debug and the release of 64 that's fine
I could also do men's size release but
I'm just gonna stick with the release
okay so we're actually done here I'm
just gonna close out all this now close
out all this close this and we've got
build we do an LS here we'll see a bunch
of new files all the visual studio stuff
and just once again I'll say it's not
normal to build everything into the same
repo at least from a/c make standard but
I'm just doing it anyway because it's
gonna make things easier so now let's
say we just wanted we just want to do
some GL fw when doing actually you know
let's let's look at the samples most
code open source code comes with some
samples so we're gonna do a file open
project or solution and what we were
just gonna open GL fw the solution here
open here we are so we'll see some tests
some examples so let's just pick one of
these examples and more throw it into
our code cuz it's gonna be essentially
the same I'm gonna change this into all
files so I can actually see their
structure I've got a lot of things going
on here and they have these little minus
signs on them which means they're not
included in the project this is called
Boyne so well let's just go to this
let's just run it let's go to set a
start a project at least 64 and while I
play there we go you got a little
classic amiga demo of a boy
yeah let's just do it we'll just go to
it
let's go to this open the files let's
open our other project what was it
called just live including lives yeah
there we go we don't really have
anything in this yet but I just want to
show you how to include y'all w3 so
they've got a lot of code here this is
kind of a lot to unpack and work with
here so let's see what they got going on
a lot of different stuff building here
oh this is all the projects that's
that's what's going on here there's like
all those sample projects in the same
folder so that's why it's so confusing I
think the only thing we really need is
this main one here the Boeing and it
should have a main so let's search for a
main and see if they got yeah
they got it down here so there's the
main so basically what they do is they
declare a GL FW window
I try to initialize GLW make sure it
doesn't fail and then they create the
window and then they set up some some
stuff and then they go through a main
loop and and do some stuff okay so if
they want it we'll just grab all this
code here in the main and I mean it's
gonna paste it into mine
can we see a bunch of red because we
haven't included GLW of course the
includes gonna look like this I think
it's GLW we don't even see it it doesn't
see it because we have included it so
now I'm gonna talk about how to include
that library from the build we did from
the other project all you do is you
right click on your project here and go
to properties and in the properties you
want to change this to all config all
platforms if it's not already and you
basically want to set up where the
headers are to JAL fw and where the
libraries are XG l fw and you also need
to link them so let's just go through
here I'm gonna do it in the C++ and
under general we have additional include
libraries so I'm going to click the drop
down here
and I'm gonna say okay since we know GL
fw is in the same folder resource slash
repos we can go back a directory from
our build and back a directory from our
project and then we go into G lfw which
is I think all lowercase and then from
here we should go into includes I
believe and that should do it
so later okay and apply and if I got
that right let me just see if I got it
right let's go into GL w it's include
not includes okay so we're gonna change
that so I'm gonna go to edit change it
to just include of course has to match
exactly one won't find it and there we
go so now we've got that I'm just gonna
hit OK here of course is more we got to
do but now it should be able to find
this so we should be able to do include
so you'll start typing in you know we
see it there Visual Studio finds it
because it's in its include path so
there we got the jail if W stuff exit
failure of course comes from standard
the C standard so will include that of
course we could just include like we
could just put negative owners on there
but we'll stick with their example and
they've got some functions here for
their callbacks that were probably
declared in the other file so what
they've got here is they do the whole
window creation they set some callbacks
I'm gonna go ahead and comment out all
these callbacks and yeah I'm just
everything here everything about the
window and there's the for loop and we
will comment out the stuff that's not
working as you can see the swap buffers
and the poll events that's fine it's not
gonna do anything right now but at least
go through this loop and oh wait if the
window closes and that breaks usually
people do while window they usually put
this as the wild clause with a knot in
front of it but this works you it was
essentially the same so and at the end
they they terminate which destroys the
window for gfw so now if we run this we
should get the GL fw popping up right
right
well we haven't linked the library yet
we've
we've got to the header and so it can
see this code but when we go to build it
it's not gonna have the object files
that it needs and we're gonna get this
linker error so that's the other part of
this is a linker so we go back into the
properties just right-click on the
include libraries go to properties and
this time we're gonna go down a little
further to the word says linker and
under linker can expand it out there's
general it's nothing really to change
here for us but input is where we're
gonna look at we're gonna look at input
pretty carefully here actually I think
we got to go up to although there's one
more thing I think it's under this VCC
directories yeah there's include
libraries or library directories yeah
that one's under this VCC so under the
input here we're gonna put the live
under the dependencies but we also got
to put the path to it in this VCC
directories so which we do first doesn't
matter I know that the opengl libe well
let's just take a look at it so we'll go
back to this folder structure where we
built and/or the lives go now this is
tricky sometimes because it goes in a
different place depending on people how
people set up their see make I'm pretty
sure on this it goes into source and
then there should be little some lives
there's a debug and a release so let's
look at yeah debug has one since I built
a debug one police has one since I built
the release and then there's also an x64
here which has a debug and release but
these are not what you think they are
just like logs so they're not the right
one now it's kind of tricky about this
is it doesn't differentiate the 32 and
64
I guess well we only built this 64 once
in lis but if we open this project and
we build with 32 ones they're supposed
to go to a different directory I don't
think GL FWC make is setup like that
which kind of throws me off a little bit
cuz usually it'll go into a really like
an x64 or an x86 and then a release and
debug sort of like this except in a
build folder yeah but in this case the
build folder is the source goes on the
source and it just has a debug and
release but they don't say what they are
however we'll get an error if they're
wrong anyway but we do gonna get the
debug and release correct
so since this is all configs all
platforms we can use some macros for
that path in later but let's go ahead
and add the glf w dot live because we
saw that's what it was Sheila W dot live
I mean let me look again
Jill fw3 dot line and this one is also
do you have Toby 3 dot live so we're
just got to get that exact live name and
hit OK hit apply and now we can go build
again we'll get the same error except
might be a little different might say
can't find it yeah there it is cannot
open file and it's because it needs the
path to this it doesn't magically know
to scan your whole computer for the live
or something you got a it would take
forever every build if it did that so
we're going to go back into properties
here and go to the VCC directories look
at the library directories see the
includes we've already got down here
it's kind of redundant but yeah we've
already got the include set up right
there the libraries however it says
different options here that's because
we're set to all platforms some of these
platforms are different you can see
there's reference path 460 for reference
perhaps 486 so when you go to all
platforms
it just says hey there's different
options but we can still edit it let me
make sure I'm well there we go
library I was I was talking about
reverence there but it's the same with
the libraries alright so we'll go to
edit these libraries and this time we're
gonna add the path once again to gfw so
we know we go back a directory from our
build folder and we go back a directory
from our project and then we can go into
GL fw 3 and then we saw that it was in
source and now this next part it could
be another deep and either debug or
lise so what we do here is we put a
macro for and the macro is just a dollar
sign and then in parentheses
configuration I hope I'm saying that I'm
hoping doing this rate so this will path
next to either whatever our
configuration is which is debug or
release so this is either the word debug
or release or if we had a midsize
release it could also go to that but for
right now we're only working with debug
and release and that's what this
configuration turns into so we're gonna
hit OK
we're gonna hit apply I don't think we
need the last slash there I think that's
actually going to bug it out because I'm
pretty sure the slash is included all
right
so there we go and that's just where GL
FW was that's that's all it is
so if Jill fw ever gets rebuilt it'll
still path to the same place where we're
building it now if you built your gfw
somewhere else like into the end of the
build it's gonna probably be GLW build
source debug all right so according to
our check-in it could be different check
for yourself all right
so now when we build this it should
succeed unless we've messed something up
ago it built and there we go we got the
window and we got there title because we
copypasta that in there we go so that's
how you include libraries from open
source stuff that's up on github and as
a see make is is just like that so you
could do this for every every one of
them and anytime gow3 master gets
updated you could pull those updates and
rebuild and get the newest latest
features right away and this is
basically how I do libraries these days
is I bring in the source in custom
lincom if it's something that's close
source and then yeah I might go download
the binaries and when and in case you
don't know the binary is this live so
you can get them pre-built for 64 32
release debug it's the same thing it's
just somebody already went through and
built it and then they just uploaded the
libe for you to link and of course you
need the headers to so that you can do
this whole thing
okay well I think that explains it
enough I'm going to do a part two of
this where maybe I add in some OpenGL
stuff if you want if you guys want let
me know below if you want to see a part
two if you want me to continue with this
I could talk more about other types of
limes I could talk about dynamic lives
I could add our other libraries like I
could start adding anything else any
other lives to this or I could show you
how to build your own lives and link
them in just with visual studio because
you can do it you can just right click
here and go to add a new project and
when you pick a project here there are
static libraries which is what GL fw3 is
there there's also dynamic libraries
which you can link in so that way you
can have a project have a bunch of
different things going on some of them
are just libraries you don't run them
you just build them every once in a
while so that your main project your
main actual executable will use those
and there you go so there's a lot to it
I think I've covered a pretty good chunk
of libraries I hope that helps someone
out there that's trying to understand
libraries more and is maybe stuck it is
essentially the same on Linux I haven't
played around libraries as much on Linux
but it's essentially the same thing you
just gotta you gotta look up the
commands to put in your make file or C
make
actually I think see Mike handles it for
you even on Linux but if you're making
your own make file then you got to look
up the commands
okay well peace out you guys I'll see
you in the next episode Mac from Co tech
materials out stay safe out there and
keep code
[Music]